I don't know what's going on there man I
had an opportunity to do to do the fake
relationship Logan Paul is out here
speaking his mind saying his brother
Jake's relationship with Tana might not
be for love why I love Tana
because we are like the same exact
person the way we think you can make
money together like say you make merch
together you probably spa that I could
fifty split I hope so like what if my
brother's like doing 8020 with Tana and
get this slogan goes as far as to say he
could have also been in a fake
relationship I had an opportunity like a
big one by the way like I could have
pounced in you know relationship that
would've like that would have lit it on
fire
come on but what was it I can't say I'm
not gonna lie things did seem a little
suspect when I talk to them about Anna
Tana Tana showed up with you guys it's a
date situation he's mainly into me but
like I don't I've been keeping it
low-key Jake more went public with it
yeah yeah there's rumors that maybe you
guys went on a first date bad but they
did and then Jake this is a better match
if I'm being honest yeah we steal each
other's girlfriends but today's Logan
news doesn't stop at fake romances the
24 year olds also sat down for a Fox
Business interview where he made yet
another claim use the word controversial
yes um just so you know I am an ex
controversial youtuber that's know what
yeah it's no longer me what I know I
know that we could we can get to that to
be fair when I talked to Logan and Jake
earlier this year
Logan talked about overcoming
controversy you what is the key to
overcoming controversy keep your head up
and and I think believing in yourself
and the message and why you originally
started creating content like it like
we're not here just because it's like I
don't know gigs and like we want to
actually do something to change the
world in a way and our way to do that is
through creative content and that's our
outlet so as long as we don't stop that
I think we'll be going following all
that controversy though logan also
discussed his current financial
situation at one point he was reportedly
earning 15
a year but despite that he has no plans
to leave YouTube anytime soon who does a
better job of monetizing for the
creator's like that is the the home for
me as a creator where not only can my
content be seen consumed digested but
also like they pay and I think Facebook
just got into monetizing content I'm so
sorry Facebook and Instagram but yeah I
don't know how much of an audience is
there right all right guys what do we
think are Jake and Tana really in love
is this the beginning of the end for
Logan let me know what you think and for
all the latest keep it locked to all
things et until next time I'm Katie
kress and bye for now